stade
rigaud
[Musique]
j'ai commencé la première compétition en
2012 voilà de façon assez sporadiques au
démarrage et puis et puis l'autre façon
un petit peu plus régulier like i'm like
light mild
la compétition on est jugé sur l'adresse
habilité le premier exercice ça va être
une recherche qui va se faire de 300 à
450 m ensuite le chien doit ramener le
plus droit possible les moutons sur nous
qui a précédé maths en fait c'est à dire
que les moutons vont être conduits en
triangle dans une ligne où il va falloir
absolument qu'ils restent dans la ligne
le plus droit possible calmement
possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'un agriculteur il a besoin
que le chien ramène le troupeau qui se
stoppe qui laissait direction et après
qu'il soit en capacité de le pousser par
exemple sur le quai de traite ou des
choses comme ça mais ça peut rester
assez grossier là en compétition on va
vraiment j'ai la dre stabilité du chien
donc on va vouloir que quand on donne un
stop il se stoppe exactement à l'endroit
où on lui a donné quoi
c'est bien révèle comme com com com et
bien ça
c'est bien ça stan station des border
collie a donc des chiens
anglais à la base c'est une race qui est
vrai sélectionné depuis presque réussi à
vendre sur ses qualités vergel donc ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est un
chien qui des six semaines va montrer
ses dispositions c'est à dire une
attitude rampante et une envie de
rassembler donc c'est vraiment des
chiens qui sont spécifiquement destinés
à du travail troupes au calme
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
en fait à la base je me destinais plutôt
à être vétérinaire et j'ai pas du tout
accroché avec tout ce qui était aspect
chirurgie et j'ai découvert
l'ostéopathie à ce moment là tout
simplement
il se met là bas
à la base les chevaux je voulais
absolument pas aller dedans et on m'a
voilà c'est le bouche à oreille qui a
fait que et j'ai un peu atterri là et en
fait ça me plaît vraiment beaucoup
allaient encore descends descends
descends
encore encore hu on aime bien toucher
effectivement quand on va dans ce cuir
sur cela après on apprend à toucher
parce que c'est vrai que nous les
premières années de ce t on sont
strictement rien et c'est hyper
frustrant m mais du temps et je pense
que la main elle cdu que tout au long de
la vie en tout cas ça bouge mieux ouais